I was beginning to feel quite
fancy something to eat but I didn't know
what to eat
except the water and that I noticed the
monkeys used to eat things they keep
eating something and I keep watching
where they get in this food and I just
took me days to find out where they get
in the food except the one of them was a
very good one
he used to grow when the some Indian
people used to fall asleep and they used
to hear the sound the people falling
asleep and he went in in the room very
quiet and he grew a lot of food out to
these room with huge amounts of fruits
and it used to carry so much that he
dropped and that was the first time I
came out and found a banana or other
things and I pick it up quickly but you
better move because if you don't they
take it away quickly so I went through
it as fast as I could always